pété le best-of de la semaine dernière
tout le monde en a parlé
donc samedi dans les deux cas social un
ami même si c'est pour les débits de
golf sur flu vieille que celui quand
même jean marie bigard
salut qui rit un ça va ça va super on
est heureux de voir
bah moi aussi il ya un paquet de fiches
j'ai vu derrière ça va chauffer beaucoup
d'invités votre catherine barma très
bien travaillé il ya beaucoup d'invités
alors on t'as demandé de venir parce que
si tu vois tu reviens sur celle au
hammam il faut que je vous vois les gens
alors on vous a demandé de venir
ah oui c'est terrible hein on vous a
demandé de venir et il faut que vous
voyez aussi d'accord ça va être
difficile il s'agit comme tu veux moi
sommes je parle couramment les deux
langues il n'y a pas de problèmes
reconnaît les différences entre une
turlute et nous jure lutte
oui ça dépend si tu la vouvoie si tu
l'as vu toi
bon alors on va faire un peu de promo
alors jean marie bigard au bataclan à
partir du 25 janvier
oui ça s'appelle bigard remet le paquet
ces gracieuses
oui c'est bien sa vie j'ai pensé que mon
affiche un slip avec mes couilles et
m'habite dedans je tiens à préciser que
c'est mon matériel est un bon c'est pas
un montage ont cédé tarder pour mettre
trois coups et puis on s'est dit ça à
faire prétentieux est resté à deux
c'était un bon compte
donc j'imagine vous planquer en sortant
de scène parce que jusqu'à sur la fiche
à les vrais potes tout seul là non
melodia je me fais du souci mois alors
il ya c'est que des sketches nouveau
dans ce spectacle comme d'habitude comme
d'habitude ouais comme 100% tout neuf là
c'est pareil c'est écrit avec qui au
bail jeu j'ai écrit 80% du spectacle
mais j'ai un co écrit beaucoup de
sketches le fameux lâcher de [ __ ] par
exemple j'ai fait avec mon ami laurent
baffie ses écrits ou ça vous êtes mieux
ou pour travailler ça c'est les
questions
toi qui sont ces questions tu vois ces
questions profondes des questions non
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya la télé allez
un peu comme la télé fait comme on dit
mais alors vous puisez votre inspiration
là j'aurais pu le faire mais je dis non
uniquement le mercredi et le vendredi
et bien sûr si tu veut puiser mais vous
l'avez écrit avec avec quoi ce spectacle
avec un stylo à papier ça l'a fait
champagne pas de pétards spectacle agen
on peut dire oui sinon je pense qu'on
écrit mieux agen est pas et pas bourré
d'accord raconte dès que tu écris un
bosquet près tu veux ressembler la
gueule ça nous rassure quand c'est un
spectacle qui a été rodé en province à
l'occasion d'un certain nombre de dates
et il y aura une tournée à l'automne
après donc le bataclan vacances et après
à l'automne rude journée et puis après
l'olympia décembre ouais décembre
janvier et puis retourner derrière bien
alors dix ans de succès puis a eu ce
film là la dernière fois qu'on s'était
vu ça y est pour ce film qui s'appelait
l'âme soeur j'ai retrouvé une
déclaration vous aviez fait juste avant
c'est ça c'est fait avec 1
et juste avant le film
alors pour vous demander gens mais des
gars pourquoi vous faisiez un film et
vous aviez répondu c'était juste avant
sa sortie
parce que c'est tellement grisant de
pouvoir toucher énormément de monde en
très peu de temps avec mes state
impassibilité avec mes spectacles en
faisant 200 dates par an j'ai mis dix
ans à faire venir deux millions de
personnes ouais et avec le film j'étais
au bord du suicide après la sortie de
mon film je dis qu'est ce que je fais je
m'ouvre les veines là ou sur le trottoir
d'en face
parfois c'était pas loin c'était l'idée
quand même un au départ et j'avais pas
fini d'écrire le spectacle maintenant
que j'ai même pas commencé j'ai dit à
pascal legros feu moyen de tourner je
verrai écrire un spectacle avant même
d'avoir écrit oui et il m'a téléphoné
dix jours après il m'a dit voilà j'ai 54
dates pour l'automne j'avais encore pas
écrit la première ligne du premier
sketch et avant de démarrer au mois de
septembre on avait presque vendu les
45000 places de la tournée donc je me
suis dit c'est quand même infernal que
les gens attendent sur scène dans les
stades dans les starting blocks
tu t'arrêtes trois ans c'est comme si tu
étais parti la veille
et puis cinéma c'est a vraiment rien à
voir maintenant je le sais tout le monde
m'avait dit tu verras ça rien à voir
mais maintenant j'en suis sûr